alle rettungsversuche sind gescheitert
der angeschlagene britische
touristikkonzern thomas cook ist
insolvent der betrieb wurde mit
sofortiger wirkung eingestellt
der britische premierminister johnson
hatte zuvor eine staatliche rettung
abgelehnt
unmittelbar betroffen sind etwa 600.000
touristen darunter mehr als
hunderttausend deutsche
zu thomas cook gehört auch der deutsche
ferienflieger condor
er beantragte bei der bundesregierung
einen überbrückungskredit
das ist die letzte thomas cook maschine
die abheben durfte
heute morgen in london in palma de
mallorca ging da schon nichts mehr
manchen wird das erst am flughafen klar
personal und kunden vereint in
ratlosigkeit
bis in den abend hatte der konzern
versucht geld von investoren zu sammeln
vergeblich verkündet der chef am morgen
in london schmallippig das ist ein
statement von dem ich gehofft hatte dass
ich es nie machen müsste ich möchte mich
entschuldigen bei all unseren kunden die
gerade im urlaub sind oder die in den
kommenden monaten mit uns eine reise
gebucht haben
von der insolvenz betroffen sind
konzernweit 600.000 urlauber auch die
deutschen tochtergesellschaften darunter
bucher neckermann und bürger haben den
verkauf von reisen gestoppt gefrustet
bleiben die versetzten zurück wie hier
in frankfurt am main
ein strandurlaub in ägypten sollte es
für diese beiden werden gebucht über
condor darf sie nicht mehr mitnehmen
ja das ist total bescheuert vor allem
haben wir die flüge auch schon gezahlt
also konto hat ja auch das geld schon
bekommen für sowohl hin- und rückflug
und trotzdem heißt es ja sie können uns
nicht mitnehmen so für touristen aus
großbritannien hat die luftfahrtbehörde
zitat größte rückholaktion in
friedenszeiten angekündigt das ist eine
riesige operation 150 tausend leuten
werden wir helfen und in den nächsten
stunden fangen wir an sie zurück nach
hause zu holen
auch die deutsche fluggesellschaft
condor gehört zur thomas cook bei der
bundesregierung hat die airline einen
überbrückungskredit beantragt um weiter
fliegen zu können
nur eine stunde weit letzte thomascook
maschine in der luft sanfte landung in
manchester das harte ende des ältesten
touristikkonzerns der welt
mit deutschen reiseveranstaltern von
thomas cook sind nach
unternehmensangaben derzeit rund 140.000
pauschalreisende unterwegs und am
frankfurter flughafen ist stefan
schlösser wie geht es jetzt für diese
urlauber weiter naja fangen wir erstmal
mit der guten nachricht an wer also
direkt bei condor gebucht hat der dürfte
keine probleme bekommen die flüge gehen
nach wie vor planmäßig anders sieht es
eben aus wie die rund 140000 deutschen
reisenden die mit thomas cook unterwegs
waren und mit deren
tochtergesellschaften über neckermann
oder im bucher reisen wie und vor allem
wann diese zurückgeholt werden das ist
im moment noch nicht klar aus
rechtlichen gründen darf condor selbst
wenn die kapazitäten frei haben
diese passagiere eben auch nicht
befördern generell ist es so dass
pauschalreisende versichert sind in der
regel wird in solchen fällen die
rückreise organisiert und die sie
kriegen ihre kosten erstattet allerdings
ist die deckungssumme beträgt in diesem
fall nur so rund 110 millionen euro und
das dürfte bei weitem nicht ausreichen
um alle ansprüche an ende zu begleichen
und wer keine pauschalreise gebucht hat
wer zum beispiel nur ein flug oder nur
ein hotel gebucht hat über einen der
reiseveranstalter für den gilt diese
versicherung überhaupt nicht es könnte
also sein dass am ende etliche reisende
auf ihren kosten zumindest ein stück
weit sitzen bleiben werden